[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
voting for round three of the 2022
podcast march madness tournament ended
yesterday in the joke world community
section welcome back to joke world by
the way my name is jake and today's
video is the results of the final four
of our podcast march madness tournament
so we had the joe rogan experience going
up against theo van in this past weekend
on one side and on the other side we had
tom segura christina p and your mom's
house going up against tom skorra bruce
kirschner and two bears one cave on the
other side now before we get into the
results let's first quickly go back
through the bracket figure out what
happened what the matches were to get to
this point who beat who and then we'll
get in to who's going on to the finals
so he started off with 16 shows in round
one region one joe rogan beat trash
tuesdays and then he'd go on to beat
uncle joey's joint in round two and
that's how he got to the final four
theo's path went against chris stefano
in round one and then against the king
to sting in the wing so against himself
in round two and now he's going up
against joe rogan in the final four your
mom's house started off against the
honeydew and then beat tiger belly in
the second round and two bears one cave
start off against hey babe and then
upset the tim dillon show in round two
and that brings us to now the final four
the joe rogan experience versus
theavonne this past weekend voted on by
you and then on the other side the ymh
vs ymh show tom against tom obviously
also voted on by you so without any
further ado let's get into it let's turn
my screen back on and show you what you
guys voted on read some comments show
some clips and get out of here we'll
start in round one with the joe rogan
experience number one overall seed going
up against theo van in this past weekend
there were 3 400 people that voted on
this and so far joe's had no problem
with the competition kind of
steamrolling through this this bracket
as a lot of people predicted but with
theo you've got to think he's got one of
the bigger audiences especially one of
the more influential audiences of this
channel
so that's what i'm surprised to see with
79
jre here really not even much of a fight
from the rat king and this wasn't even
that different from joe's other matchups
you know i thought this would would have
been the best chance that joe had to
lose but
let's see round one he beat trash
tuesday's 91 to 9
and then in round two it was it was
against uncle joey and it was 80 to 20
so i guess this was as close as one by
one percent
theo did better than joey diaz by one
percent but
joe rowing experience proves to be
attacked
salute gentlemen salud happy birthday my
brother thank you for many more thank
you young jamie
thank you thank you all whoo
tremendous they're not in the same
category plus a reference question would
be useful if the question was to be for
example what podcast is funniest maybe
thea would win
um i think they are in the same category
a little bit you know podcasts hosted by
comedians but i do get what you mean
here's the reference question for the
rest of this tournament
which podcast do you want to move on to
the next round of the tournament like
that's just vote for your favorite one i
mean we might be overthinking it a
little bit
i feel like a lot of people are voting
on the podcast as a whole when it really
should just be how good the podcast has
been the last six months to a year am i
wrong or does this make more sense for
march madness and i favorited this one
because that i didn't think of that i
never announced that i should have
thought of that that is so true
the real march madness tournament works
with the hottest teams who have you know
the most momentum tend to go farther
into the tournament so this
all should have been based on what's
producing the best content recently um
so yeah i don't know
i don't know if that would have played
into your voting or not
but that's a really good point by hunter
godwin jerry never belonged in this poll
joe rogan isn't even a comedy podcast a
lot of comments kind of reiterating that
point but it's like we don't want to
punish someone for having too big of a
platform one two joe's a comedian three
he's the reason that theo even has a
podcast and theo has said that before
that going on joe's show was one of the
main reasons he wanted to create this
past weekend so it's like we're not
gonna take him out because he has the
biggest platform and is probably gonna
win this you know you don't take duke
out of the tournament because they have
coach k
so not that i'm a big duke or coach k
guy but i needed a
a good analogy i don't know maybe we
could do one next year without the joe
rogan experience but then it just seems
like there's gonna be a bunch of
comments going you know the joe rogan
experience would have swept this thing
so it's like you can't
what do you want from me man joerg
experience moves on to the finals this
past weekend a final four run that's
that's a hell of a run by them um
still can be your favorite podcast this
tournament doesn't have to change your
opinion on anything but we're moving on
to round two nonetheless which is the
ymh super show this is interesting to me
because your mom's house has been along
for so much longer and it's really if
you're a fan of tom's podcasting it's
where you got to know him but some of
the biggest hits some of the biggest
highlights that go viral are
from two bears one cave i mean off the
top of your head you can name the
kool-aid the jennifer aniston the
matthew mcconaughey thing so many
different moments there where it's just
like this is so funny so
this is more of an interesting question
for like the tom diehard fans but there
were 3 000 votes
it was 62 to 38
with the winning podcast being your
mom's house the mommy's pulled through
that's who i was rooting for let's go
it's your mom's house show here
obviously joke world getting the shout
out from your mom's house those are my
boys at joke world
that's who did it
um and the world is wrld as soon as i
came across ymh over four years ago
instantly became my favorite source of
entertainment hopefully they'll win the
joker of march madness tourney i mean
they do have more consistent jokes than
jre so this guy's already lining up the
next matchup he saw theo had to go
against joe and he saw that ymh had to
go against two bears and he's like i
know for a fact that this is gonna be
the finals i love both but two bears is
more of a dad podcast ymh will give you
some visual reactions sometimes been
around ymh since the hey hitler day has
been consistently wild and funny that's
real og and you can tell the ymh people
who got there at what point based on
what inside jokes that they uh usually
reference and so
hey hitler was real og i remember
listening back in those days it was
really neat i walked on stage
one of my shows and a girl was sitting
in the front row and with a marker she
had written on her forehead hey hitler
so you look at a girl with a marker yeah
and i'm like oh
jesus or lipstick i don't know let's
just i go hey hitler's on your forehead
hilarious she's like yeah i'm like and
all these people were like hey look
screaming hey hitler
guys the club uh the employees are like
what is going on
the other comment or the other audience
members were like why is that going on
uh the hey hitler theme has been one of
my favorite because it's probably the
most inappropriate thing we've ever seen
far the most yeah but it's the most fun
and look if you're on board you're on
board if you're not go [ __ ] yourself
you're not a mommy my mates fell off
bears all day now get in my fenced area
so there are some bears out here too
there's also
um a lot of comments like this two bears
one cave is burping an insufferable
degenerate and tom laughing at him your
mom's house is an overall wholesome
husband and wife dynamic
there are a lot of anti-burp comments in
this section that's just like i love
both but recently bert has been getting
on my on my nerves and and two bears or
people even saying that he just ruined
the whole show and then pointing to
things like oh every episode is tom
trying to set up a joke and then burp
being like huh i can't stop drinking and
i eat too much and i had sex with my
wife and i don't know if she liked it
and it's like
just trying to get a reaction out of tom
and then get a clip out of that and go
viral again like i i agree with a lot of
what these people are saying i don't
know if he's ruined the show because he
also brings a lot of
really authentic funny moments to the
show but i can agree with um a little
bit of his shtick seems a little played
out where it's like
okay you have
com a problem with compulsion
is there any other joke besides that
because we've we've kind of you know
rang that out all it can be maybe not i
don't know what i'm saying dude i'm a
big bird fan i'm a big two bears fan
either way your mom's house is going to
the finals two bears one cave is an
amazing show so is this past weekend the
final four in the real march madness
tournament you get credit for even
making to the final four like you're one
of the best people hang banners in their
gyms that say like final four 2022 so
these four teams maybe will send a
banner to their po box it says joke
world final four 2022 but uh four
amazing super funny um shows that i tune
into every week and i'm excited to see
joe rogan experience go up against your
mom's house in the finals i'm sure you
guys are all excited too a lot of people
are calling this from the start because
they're literally the two biggest
audiences so i don't know what we're
going to do to maybe fix this next year
to make it a little bit more fair but
there's a lot of time in between now and
then to think of what that could be
so thank you for watching
thank you for voting thank you for
participating liking subscribing thank
you for following the channel thank you
for being a part of joke world and thank
you to everyone who's following us on
instagram those are the main use ymh has
their main mommies those are you're
touching my camera through the fence if
you're following joker on instagram
because we're trying to get this thing
up and running we're featuring a new
comedian every day a 60-second bit of
their standup that they send into us and
then we feature it out to everyone to
get them shown it's a really cool thing
it's cool platform that we're trying to
develop and kind of you know
help comedy progress so i hope your real
brackets are going well too and i hope
that you're having a good time watching
real march madness and i hope that you
own stuff that you that is ugly and that
you want to like
make look better with workstream this is
such a bad transition but get these
stickers dude from our instagram and
just dm us and we'll send you these
stickers like i don't know why you don't
get them come on get the stickers
all right well
[Music]
you